we are told the differentiable function
h and its derivative h prime are graphed
and you can see it here h is in blue and
then its derivative h prime is in this
orange color
four students were asked to give an
appropriate calculus based justification
for the fact that h is increasing when x
is greater than zero can you match the
teacher's comments to the justifications
so before i even look at what the
students wrote you might say hey look i
can just look at this and see that h is
increasing when x is greater than zero
but just by looking at the graph of h
that by itself is not a calculus based
justification we're not using calculus
we're just using our knowledge of what
it means for a graph to be increasing in
order for it to be a calculus based
justification we should use calculus in
some way so maybe used the derivative in
some way now we you might recognize that
you know that a function is increasing
if its derivative is positive so before
i even look at what the student said
what i would say my calculus based
justification
and i wouldn't even have to see the
graph of h i would just have to see the
graph of h prime is to say look h prime
is greater than h prime is positive when
x is greater than zero if the derivative
is positive then that means that the
slope of the tangent line is positive
and that means that the graph of the
original function is going to be
increasing now let's see whether one of
the students said that or what some of
the other students wrote
so can you match the teacher's comments
to the justifications so one student
wrote the derivative of h is increasing
when x is greater than zero
so it is indeed the case that the
derivative is increasing when x is
greater than zero but that's not the
justification for why h is increasing
for example the derivative could be
increasing while still being negative in
which case h would be decreasing the
appropriate justification is that h
prime is positive not that it's
necessarily increasing because you could
be increasing and still not be positive
so let's see
i would say
that this doesn't justify why h is
increasing
when x is greater than 0 as the x values
increase the function values also
increase
well that's
that is a justification for why h is
increasing but that's not calculus based
and no way are you using a derivative
so this isn't a calculus based
justification
it's above the x-axis
so this one what are they what is it are
they talking about h are they talking
about h prime if they're saying that h
prime is above the x-axis when x is
greater than zero then that would be a
good answer but this is just
you know what is above the x-axis and
over what interval so i would actually
let's scroll down a little bit
this looks like a good thing for the
teacher to write please use more precise
language this cannot be accepted as a
correct justification
and then finally this last student wrote
the derivative of h is positive when x
is greater than zero and it is indeed
the case if your derivative is positive
that means that your original function
is going to be increasing over that
interval so kudos you are correct